just how easy is it to launder money in
Germany Hamburg the country's major port
city is a good place to find out we
start off with the proverbial briefcase
full of cash our first stop is a bank
where as we know from our research most
funny money arriving in Germany ends up
together with the legitimate kind [ __ ]
like all german banks the humble
graphics bank has a money laundering
reporting officer so what is the folks
bunk do when somebody comes in with a
briefcase full of cash others when we
talk to that person to try to find out
what exactly is going on you can believe
me that people who have been active in
the market for years they've developed a
fine sense for how someone reacts when
they answer questions you leave yet
emaar the replies spontaneous incredible
or do you sense that they just thought
something up as an answer Ziva would
have had my head in a loop that seemeth
guardian because I know find bizarre
unported and what happens when someone
transfers money electronically for the
purpose of laundering it the bank has
software to monitor all transactions and
point do anything unusual and RFI in an
actual case we had some time ago
involved a student we knew his income
situation and what drew our attention
was repeated account movements for the
purchase and sale of cars and that was
unusual for his financial situation and
that's fine food besides we could tell
they were big expensive cars he was
dealing in from the reference field 100
they were Mercedes and Audi's and so on
was it as farming terraces foul deed up
I
dealing in real estate is another very
popular way to launder money in Germany
often front men are used to obscure the
buyers true identity
experts are well aware that this method
is a favorite with Italian crime
syndicates Ingo Fiedler of the
University of Hamburg does research on
money laundering detail in hasn't noon
fish the Italian authorities have been
cracking down on the map here with
anti-money laundering campaigns oz by so
organized crime has responded by moving
to other countries where it's easier to
operate Germany is geographically close
to Italy and a large economic power so
the Italian mafia has been trying to
become active in Germany gambling
arcades are also being used more and
more to launder dirty money behinds and
growling arcades are very well suited to
money laundering for the simple reason
that they're not as closely regulated
they don't have to worry about the
anti-money laundering laws the way other
sectors do where institutions are bound
by these laws so the operator the arcade
can simply over report his revenues he
can say he took in a million when it was
actually 500,000 just by manipulating
the machines the other five hundred
thousand is dirty money that's money
laundering and it's profitable feed
the laundered money has to be stashed
away in a safe investment what are the
chances of the money launderer getting
caught stanky that special God's
daughters I think they're well below one
hundred percent nice it's impossible to
do better the ambush League anyone who's
out to make these transactions and
launder their money is going to put some
thought into it they'll come up with
tactics and methods to keep it all in
the wraps and we won't be able to find
out every single case I'll give at least
Eden file it in deccan country Germany's
image could suffer if more is not done
to combat money laundering it's still
too easy to get away with it that was
our impression